hallo leute ich sie teure mal waren und
willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute stellen wir uns der
allerwichtigsten frage wie woher hast du
das in meiner laufbahn als erfolgreiche
youtuber in wenn ich sogar die
erfolgreich also während dieses bekomme
ich sehr oft die frage gestellt vanessa
woher hast du punkt punkt punkt und ab
und zu versuche ich mal solche fragen
auch zu beantworten aber ich kann ja
nicht die ganze zeit den leuten darunter
schreiben das sie übrigens der
lippenstift ist von daun und die brille
habe ich von da und da und also
jugendbetreuung aber es wäre auch
irgendwie unfair diese fragen so gar
nicht zu beantworten
deswegen habe ich mir paar rausgesucht
die oft gestellt werden bzw in der
letzten zeit aufgestellt wurden
und bitteschön hier kommt meine liste
von dingen die ich habe und woher also
macht euch gefasst auf ein produkt
gewitter wie es noch nie da war sehr
schön wenn ich mit diesem video so
hammer viel geld verdienen könnte aber
außer amazon erfüllt links habe ich nix
anderes deswegen wenn ich was bei amazon
findet damals mit philipp lingg darunter
also wenn ihr mich unterstützen wollen
können sie über den link kaufen wenn ihr
euch das nachkochen wollt aber ansonsten
werde ich das einfach vielleicht noch in
die kommentare ranch alten in die
beschreibung sein schreiben
wer gut woher hast du das oberteil das
ist so schön wie man unschwer erkennen
kann ist dieses oberteil von adidas und
ich habe es von kelly ich habe eine
frage woher ist dieses rote oberteil von
adidas was du mir gegeben hast ja was
gekauft
ich glaube
auch dass er talkshow ok danke schön
mehr war der top show ich drehe gerade
ein video in dem sich alle fragen
beantworten woher ich was haben der
blazer ist so schön hast zu dem der
blazer ist vom bershka und ich habe ihn
für die allergien kino-premiere gekauft
man habe ich ihn gekauft jetzt ja ich
glaube den gibt es nicht mehr aber ich
muss sagen die bergstadt qualität finde
ich jetzt nicht so optimal dein weißer
pulli ist megaschön woher hast du den
also dem bulli ist schon ein
wunderschöner aber wenn ich ihn nur
einmal an probiere ist immer make-up
dran und dann kann ich schon mal wieder
in die wäsche speisen dieses oberteil
ist vorn
sparks ich liebe auch dieses oberteil
ich habe es ganz zufällig in einem
kölner laden gefunden als ich für die
dann die partie was gesucht habe
die salami in köln wartet wie heißt noch
mal der laden kennt schreibt der laden
heißt goldeck und ist am friesenwall 32
bis 36 groß empfehlung da finde ich
immer schöne klamotten was ich besonders
cool an dieser politik finde ist dass da
immer so ausgewählten klamotten sind
also auch von vero moda und pieces oder
anderen marken aber man merkt dass die
boutique besitzerin guten geschmack hat
und echt eigentlich alles schön da drin
ist und nun trommelwirbel
woher hast du deine brille leute nun
bekommt ihr die antwort woher habe ich
diese wunderschöne iconic brille
ich habe diese brille bei mister spex
geholt und zwar nicht online sondern im
store im alexa in berlin die brille ist
von s die brille ist von escada escada
ist eine marke die man kennt oder die
war relativ teuer das weiß ich und die
habe ich dort bei mister spex machen
lassen anfängt zu dieser brille mit
ihrem mann es sieht ich saß letztens mit
timo im restaurant und mir ist das
brillenglas einfach raus gefallen und
dann habe ich gemerkt dass die schraube
die das gestellt um das glas so festhält
rausgefallen ist und dadurch hat das
glas ausgefallen ist und dann bin ich zu
mister spex und die haben mir halt eine
viel zu große schraube da jetzt rein
gemacht hier und auf der seite ist diese
schraube nicht zu sehen ja soviel dazu
woher hast du deinen wäscheständer
dieser wäscheständer ist von aldi und
zwar habe ich ihn vor vier jahren
gekauft oder fünf als ich nach berlin
gezogen bin ich habe arbeiten sehen dass
obi glaube ich den gleichen hat hier
kommen richtig die housewives weil der
mega praktisch ist er auf jeden fall
sehr viel platz sparender als diese
großen
[Musik]
beste entscheidung meines lebens ist von
einem guten wäscheständer will man
natürlich auch immer die marke wissen
gimme gimme gimme gimme woher hast du
deine hose
die sieht aus als würde sie extrem gut
sitzen meine hose ist von bdg also die
urban outfitters marke ich muss auch
sagen das ist die beste rose die ich
jemals besessen habe es sehr gemütlich
sie geht immer wieder auf ihre ursprungs
größe zurück sie vermischt sich
eigentlich kaum ich habe sie leider
schon zerstört und farbe und so aber
trotzdem werde ich sie für immer
behalten
geil der pulli mit google+ sag mir wo er
den hass
dieser pool ist teil einer werbekampagne
gewesen denn wer lesen kann sieht hier
dass hier steht pixel 3 und dann ganz
viele google einträge für das pixel drei
ich finde den auch mega cool muss haben
wir sagen damals hat mir google
geschrieben und meinte hey wir würden
die gerne was zu schicken und mich so oh
mein gott schicken sie mir das pixel 3er
ja bitte und dann kriege ich den pulli
in andere leute kriegen smartphones
hinterhergeworfen ich kriege police in
sachen sind mir schwer in sachen wir
nochmal so fusselig und so jetzt habe
ich dann berg mit sachen anstatt es
immer wieder an seinen platz zu bringen
schmeiße ich es ich bin zu unordentlich
woher hast du das kleine schweinchen auf
der schuh kommode sagt hallo zu frida
reader ist wirklich das schönste geld
schwein guckt euch mal dieses liebe
gesicht an und ich will ja nicht angeben
woher dieses schweinchen ist gut gefüllt
das schwein war ein geschenk von timos
schwester an timo aber ich hab's auch
amazon gefunden also verlinke ich es
euch unten woher hast du das bild in
deiner essecke ganz kurzer fun fact zu
dem gottesacker vendetta hat man die
lustigste story dazu erzählt und zwar
dachte sie ganz lange dass es ecke ein
türkisches wort ist für essecke proxxon
aventador für diesen hammer zog und das
bild ist von der künstlerin vanessa wenn
ich habe es selbst gemacht wie
komplimente können jetzt einmal
einfließen danke ja ich weiss ahlen auf
bänken und ich hab mich ja mit feng shui
beschäftigt und laufschuhe ist die ecke
von unserer ecke in der partnerschaft
ecke und dann soll man da so paar sachen
drauf hängen anbringen so schwer das
bild ich lasse es jetzt einfach auf das
treffen sie versteckt woher hast du die
strickjacke die ist hammer cute die
strickjacke ist von meiner mutter als es
angefangen hat kein zu
dann habe ich zu ihm gesagt hey ich hab
gar keine warme sachen und dann hat sie
von oben aus ihrem zimmer das hier
mitgebracht und es ist von dem allseits
bekannten und beliebten label up to
fashion und da zeigt es sich mal wieder
dass wenn man trennen die aussehen
möchte keine marken brauch mal woher
hast du die tapioka perlen bin ich ganz
sicher ob es in dem video nicht verlinkt
habe aber die tapioka perlen sind
natürlich von amazon weil immer wenn ich
so random schiff brauche police bei
amazon
sorry sondern verlinkt woher hast du
dieses geile t shirt jetzt frau d day
and all of us to cut the thing that
thought to thank you
woher hast du deinen pulli noch nie
weißt du froh dass jemand das gefragt
hat riesa pulli ist von alexander den
habe ich in new york gekauft bei macy's
wieser pulli hat 450 dollar gekostet
thank you baby kleinste details zu
diesem pulli ich habe den in new york
gekauft und dann habe ich ihn mit nach
hause genommen
und weil hier drin steht dass man ihn
mit der hand waschen soll habe ich ihnen
immer nicht gewaschen sondern dann halt
in meinem schrank und ich wusste dass
ich ihn waschen muss aber ich wollte ihn
mit zur reinigung bringen oder gucken
wie ich ihn selber mit dampf oder so
waschen kann und dann hat ihn timo
einmal auf dem bett liegen sie und in
die waschmaschine geschmissen und bei 30
grad gewaschen was gar nicht so schlimm
ist aber dann hat er den lassen poly
zwei tage lang in dieser waschmaschine
vergessen und als ich dann die wäsche
endlich mal raus geholt habe nachdem ich
sie noch mal durchgespielt habe habe ich
gesehen dass er meinen 450 dollar pulli
gewaschen hat mein herz vor allem habe
ich ihn danach nie getragen weil ich ihn
immer nicht gewaschen hat weil ich mich
nicht getraut habe ihn falsch zu waschen
und dann schmeißt im kino einfach so in
die wäscherei
das das schönste an beziehungen
zusammenleben du hast einfach keine
kontrolle über nichts
woher hast du einfach diese marlboro
tasche ich will die auch also sie ist
von dieser marke bei diesem totenkopf
denken was man nicht sieht ich habe
diese tasche auch in new york gekauft in
einem ganz schnuckligen laden der ganz
viel crazy stuff hatte und ich weiß
nicht wieso ich musste diese tasche
unbedingt mitnehmen auch wenn es mit
zigarettenschachteln ist ich finde sie
hat so viel style ja hausnummer moore
ich habe diese tasche irgendwo mal
online gesehen auf jeden fall hat sie
sehr viel geld gekostet also irgendwas
bei 500 dollar war schon extrem woher
hast du deine lashes diese frage um
meine wimpern ist auch eine der
meistgestellten die ich jemals bekommen
habe meine wimpern wie ich jetzt zurzeit
gerade nicht habe und ich habe mir falls
sie sehen könnt wimpern extensions mal
dran machen lassen meine wimpern die
jetzt da nicht drin sind sind vorn lag
von der hardt czh
mit kollektion die lacke lockstöcke auf
jeden fall sind das die berlin das ding
das ich hab mir gerade gestern das erste
mal wimpern extensions dran machen
lassen weil ich wirklich so gerne volle
wimpern habe und jedes mal diese zu
kleben ist ein bisschen aufwendig
allerdings sind auch will man extensions
so unglaublich teuer dass ich nicht weiß
ob ich das hier weitermachen kann
wer durch die wimpern mal unten
verlinken sie kosten acht euro 95 woher
hast du das t shirt ich liebe strange
things ja leute auch wieder so items die
ihr alle wissen wollt meine strange
things t shirts ich habe zwei stück das
eine habe ich schon mittlerweile zum
kropp gemacht weil so große quichote
irgendwie auch nicht mehr so beliebt
sind diese teams jetzt habe ich von der
marke pull and bear und sie haben
wirklich eine gute qualität ich habe sie
schon oft in die waschmaschine
geschmissen und sie sind perfekt wenn
ich sie natürlich online noch finde dann
verlinke ich sie euch aber es kann sein
dass die schon wechseln
woher hast du das hemd das hemd das eine
helmut haller das hände von tommy teams
und zwar habe ich mir das im sommer
gekauft ich wahrnehmen sie es noch haben
auf jeden fall trage ich es gerne als
kleid und nicht so im winter weil das
hält nicht wahr und ich weiß gar nicht
wie es also oversize wir dazu eine hose
anhat dann sieht das irgendwie woher
hast du das waffeleisen das waffeleisen
habe ich wie die meisten sachen von
amazon ich verlinke euch das unten das
habe ich während der kochbuch zeit
gekauft also als wir es gemacht haben
und seitdem nicht noch einmal verwendet
und ich ärgere mich darüber doch mit
freddy und kelly haben wir waffen
gemacht ärgert mich aber ein bisschen
wenn man sowas holt was man einmal
irgendwie cool findet aber es nicht
wirklich einen nutzen hat für every day
dann ja genauso wie mit einer
eismaschine in entsafter habe ich nicht
aber auch so das sind so geräte die sind
nice to have aber wirklich so selten im
gebrauch woher hast du das lama bild
leute dieses lama bild ist bei euch so
krass gut angekommen dass man
mittlerweile mal wanne lama bild
eingeben kann bei google und da kommt
man auch das lama wird es ist nämlich
von maison die morgen und ich wollte
unbedingt mit denen in kooperationen
machen aber sie finden mich einfach
scheiße deswegen hier um eure lama
bedürfnisse zu befriedigen aber
mittlerweile hängt es sind für das bild
es ist nämlich riesig und man hat nicht
so viel platz woher hast du die ketten
die seen voll geil aus ich bin ehrlich
mit euch ich lese niemals so gerne meine
kommentare
wenn ich diesen pulli anhat denn es ist
ein nike polo auf dem ketten drauf
gesteckt sind und so oft wollt ihr
wissen woher ich diese ketten haben
gehören zum pulli das sind keine echten
ketten die bewegen sich auch nicht wenn
man sich bewegt ist dem ein oder anderen
vielleicht nicht aufgefallen hast du
dein oberteil selber gemacht wenn nicht
woher hast du es ich hab sie nicht
selber gemacht die habe ich beim ask
world bestellt kleiner fun fact hier
ich musste das kostüm an den seiten
aufschneiden weil die arme so dünn war
ich glaube kenne ja herr lee hat sie
auch angeschnitten das war nicht ohne
chance ach so das sind die kleider von
two broke girls und wir haben sie
benutzt als wir noch etwas tun
woher hast du den calvin klein jeans
pulli leute es gibt so kleidungsstücke
die kaufst du und erst nach ein paar
wochen merkst du das ist eines seiner
lieblings oberteile für immer sein wird
so ist auch dem calvin klein jeans pulli
ein kropf top oberteil das sich zurzeit
nicht mehr so auftrage weil mein bauch
ein bisschen dicker geworden ist als ich
es damals gekauft habe hatte ich einen
wirklichen flachen bauch das habe ich
definitiv basis gestellt
so soll es wie ihr wollt oh mein gott
dein outfit steht die übrigens mega gut
woher hast du dein t-shirt dieses t
shirt ist von monkey und zwar habe ich
das zusammen mit meiner nichte gekauft
da haben wir uns komplett gleiches
outfit gekauft und ich liebe es wenn man
sich im partnerland sieht ja jetzt ich
muss aber sagen monkey qualität gefällt
mir halt gar nicht woher hast du das
oberteil vanessa das oberteil habe ich
glaube ich auch von acers ja manchmal
findet man da so ein richtiges
schmuckstück dieses oberteil würde ich
sagen ist so ein ding danach fragt ihr
jedes mal wenn ich es im video an hab
ich muss auch sagen ich fühle es nicht
immer es gibt tage da will ich das
unbedingt anziehen und an manchen tagen
was hat ist dadurch diesen kragen hat
zum leichten charlie sheen charakter und
es ist von der marke milquet also
vielleicht findet ihr es oder ich mal
gucken woher hast du den kuli diesen
pulli
habe ich für zehn euro bei ebay
geschossen und es ist einfach mein
absoluter lieblingspulli ich weiß nicht
warum der so krass reduziert war ich
glaube auch regional hat irgendwie 40
gekostet oder so oder 50 euro m und den
kann man so richtig nice überwerfen und
einfach rausgehen und sagen hier bin ich
woher hast du diesen pullover dieser
pullover ist von asos eigenmarken und
ihr dürft niemand verraten dass ich ihn
zu hause habe denn er gehörte zu guten
morgen internet und den hat eigentlich
glaube ich freddy immer getragen
es ist ein männlicher xl pulli und wenn
man als frau dieses ding trägt dieses
winters computer ariane kranz
es ist ein schöner pullover ich habe ihn
mit gesagt ich glaube ich hatte ihn aus
versehen einfach an und bin nach hause
gegangen und dann habe ich ihn halt
vergessen zurückzugeben da aber nie
jemand nach diesem pullover gefragt hat
freue ich mich sehr dass ich immer noch
im besitz hat woher hast du deine
schüsseln meine schüsseln also
die habe ich von meiner mutter ich weiß
nicht woher die sind ich habe absolut
viele dinge die ich habe sind aus meiner
mutters küche weil meine mutter sehr
gerne online shop und mir dann sachen
gibt woher hast du diesen bunt
gemusterten kissen bezug der ist richtig
schön hammer schön ist der dieses bunt
gemusterte kissen habe ich von rom 24
und zwar habe ich damals so gut gemacht
als ich in die letzte wohnung frisch
eingezogen bin da habe ich nämlich alles
was mir gefällt einfach ausgeschnitten
und bei photoshop zusammengestellt und
so konnte ich mein perfektes wohnzimmer
schrieb sich esszimmer zusammenstellen
ich habe noch nie so organisiert
eingekauft weil ich sonst immer nur 2 kg
oder zu irgendeinem anderen möbelhaus
und sagt ja das gefällt mir das auch und
dann kauf ich alles und am erker am ende
das ist einfach nicht zusammenpasst und
als ich das so bei photoshop bevor ich
etwas bestellt habe dann wird es
ausgetauscht neue stühle neue
kissenbezüge und vor allem so ein
kissenbezug macht auch so viel mit der
einrichtung wenn du irgendwie so farben
wieder aufgreifen möchtest benutzen
kissen dafür in meiner neuen wohnung
habe ich es nicht gemacht da war ich
nicht so organisiert da wieder imperiale
möbel genommen die ich habe und zusammen
gewürfelt und da ich kenne werde ich
euch jetzt gar keine möglichkeit geben
was sind schlecht für den algorithmus
ist aber ich gebe euch keine möglichkeit
jetzt eine wohl erste frage zu stellen
also meine wimpern habe ich bei heli
slap in berlin machen lassen tolle frau
toller salon mir hat es glaube ich im
männer gemacht sehr große empfehlung
mein lippenstift von nyx mein haar wand
ist von acers mein oberteil ist von
edited das ist mein absoluter neuer
lieblings shopping laden die haben
einfach so richtig stilvolle klamotten
die aber trotzdem und manchmal so
[Musik]
mein schrank ist von ikea viele kugel
habe ich geschenkt bekommen diese
pflanze ist von meiner original großen
monster ein baby was ich gerade
heranzüchtet damit diese umtopfen kann
mein freund habe ich in korea
doch leute stellt wie viele fragen ich
liebe es wenn ihr kommentare schreibt
ich liebe es kommentare durchzulesen und
ich bin jedes mal so traurig wenn unter
dem video so wenig kommentare stehen
also denk dran
ich lese eigentlich fast jedes kommentar
ich freue mich über jedes kommentare und
ich werde in zukunft natürlich weiterhin
gucken dass ihr euch immer verraten
woher ich etwas habe und nun kann ich
essen gehen denn ich habe hunger
ich hoffe euch das video gefallen wenn
dem so ist dann zeigt es mir mit dem
daumen nach oben das hilft mir und
meinen kanal und kommentiert fleißig
abonniert diesen kanal wenn ihr meine
neuen videos nicht verpassen wollt dann
könnt ihr das kostenlos auf meinen
nacken machen also und abonnieren
ich weiß ich bin ich bin heute irgendwie
irgendwie bin ich heute komisch drauf es
dann leute